this video is sponsored by babel the
number one language learning app in the
world here's something that you probably
know if you drink too much you'll get
drunk and if you drink too much for too
many years you'll damage your liver this
is something everyone over the age of 21
already knows however there's a lot
about alcohol that people don't know for
example alcohol even a single drink
affects nearly every organ in your body
not just your liver in this video i'll
be discussing all the different things
that alcohol does to your body from the
one drink you have at a party two years
of chronic drinking the month of january
is almost over and statistically
speaking 64 percent of you watching this
video have already given up on your new
year's resolution if your resolution was
to learn a new skill what better skill
to learn than a new language through
babble i get it it's hard to devote time
to something new and actually stay with
it which is why so many people give up
but this is why babel is perfect babble
gives you quick and easy 10-minute
lessons per day you don't need to be an
overachiever to learn a new language you
just need 5 minutes twice a day
these quick and easy lessons are made by
actual language instructors who craft
real world and practical conversations
so what you're learning can be used in a
real one-to-one conversation with babel
you can start speaking a new language in
just three weeks which is about the same
time most people give up on their new
year's resolution so why not give it a
shot babel is offering a deal of 65 off
your subscription with a 20-day
money-back guarantee this is something
you don't want to miss so try it now
ethanol is the specific alcohol molecule
we drink in alcoholic beverages and this
molecule has no business being in our
body whatsoever from the moment we drink
it to the last molecule that's been
metabolized it causes harmful effects
first off ethanol is a moderate nonpolar
solvent meaning it can dissolve lipids
fairly well when it comes into contact
with lipids in our cell membrane it
causes irritation and mild inflammation
secondly when ethanol is metabolized
it's converted into acetaldehyde which
is very toxic and accounts for the
majority of the damage no matter how you
slice it there's really no way to
justify drinking alcohol it's just all
around harmful and yet when i was doing
research for this video i had a glass of
wild turkey bourbon two fingers with
chill whiskey stones i take my drink
seriously where to begin well let's go
top down so the brain first alcohol gets
us drunk because of the receptors that
it binds to in the brain specifically
ethanol binds to the gaba receptors in
the limbic system and thereby enhances
the effects of the gaba neurotransmitter
the role of the gaba neurotransmitter is
to slow down signaling of the nervous
system typically gaba has a mild effect
however when alcohol binds to the gaba
receptor it changes the receptor
physiology so that when the gaba
neurotransmitter binds to it the
inhibitory effects are much stronger
this is why alcohol is a nervous system
depressant because it increases gaba's
ability to slow down signaling of the
nervous system also quick note it's not
true that drinking too much alcohol
kills brain cells if that were the case
there would be millions of people every
year in a persistent vegetative state
however alcohol does impair the body's
ability to absorb thiamine or vitamin b
your brain needs thymine to maintain
enzymes in your brain cells if you're
thymine deficient for too long these
enzymes are non-functional and as a
result brain cells die this is a
phenomenon that occurs with some
alcoholics known as werner korsikov
syndrome alcohol inhibits the uptake of
thymine and if an alcoholic goes on a
drinking binge for several days and
doesn't eat either from being passed out
or vomiting up stomach contents they
don't have sufficient thymine intake as
a result they become thymine deficient
thereby causing brain cells to die
here's a heartbreaking example of
wernicke korsakoff syndrome in a
middle-aged man this affects a lot of
people's lives
two years ago
my brother don had been found on his
floor
unresponsive
he had laid there for at least five days
because there was five newspapers on his
porch he had drank
so much that
he ended up
with something is called warnickies
i think some people caught wet brain
which i've never heard of it before this
happened
and
he was in the hospital
for about two weeks and he was in
mcmurray hills
manor nursing home
and then the nursing home said that
there was nothing else they could do for
him and they wanted him to leave there
so
not realizing how hard this was going to
be i brought him home with me his
current condition
is um
he uh he has dementia
and he has
no memory even his longtime memory
he remembers little bits of things but a
lot of things like i've showed him a
couple places where we lived and he
doesn't remember
and it's hard because
like i had said before
you you lose yourself you you know you
lose yourself in this like it
everything is him
next onto the digestive system if the
alcohol you're drinking is more than 15
alcohol by volume it can delay digestion
of food in the stomach and intestines
concentrations at 15 or higher denatures
digestive enzymes needed to break down
food as a result bacteria in your gut
digest the food for you and release
their own gaseous byproducts causing
abdominal discomfort among other things
at the intestines alcohol is absorbed
into the blood it's true that some
alcohol does get absorbed through the
stomach but most is through the
intestines all the alcohol you drank is
now in your blood and gets sent
throughout your body some alcohol does
pass through your lungs and because
ethanol has a low molecular weight and
is quite volatile it gets exhaled with
carbon dioxide this is how breathalyzers
are able to measure your blood alcohol
content because you're exhaling ethanol
molecules into the breathalyzer which
then calculates how much alcohol is in
your blood as ethanol vapors pass
through your respiratory system that is
your bronchioles trachea nose and mouth
it irritates and damages sensitive
tissue such as mucous membranes and
cilia again alcohol is a solvent and
solvents damage cells granted the damage
that ethanol causes upon exhalation is
very minor and not enough to notice
however if you drink a lot of alcohol
for an extended period of time damage
will become significant there's a
condition called alcoholic lung where
cilia and immune cells get severely
damaged from chronic drinking so much
that they cannot fight against common
microbes that you inhale often leading
to respiratory infections according to
the cdc people who chronically abuse
alcohol are 10 times more likely to
develop pneumonia and are four times
more likely to die from it than
non-drinkers alcoholic lung can occur as
early as six weeks with four drinks per
day being high risk
at the heart alcohol causes an increase
in your heart rate known as tachycardia
subsequently raising your blood pressure
it's believed alcohol causes tachycardia
due to interference with the electrical
system of the heart it may seem odd that
alcohol slows down your nervous system
yet increases your heart rate though it
actually makes sense because the heart's
electrical system is separate from the
nervous system which is why it can beat
outside the body by itself though
alcohol does raise blood pressure having
an occasional drink is of no concern the
australian heart foundation suggests
that more than two drinks per day
greatly increases the risk for high
blood pressure next alcohol affects your
kidneys although indirectly ethanol
blocks the release of the hormone
vasopressin in the pituitary gland in
the brain vasopressin is responsible for
telling the kidneys to reabsorb water
back into the body after it filters out
toxins in the blood however with
vasopressin blocked the kidneys are not
told to reabsorb water
and as a result the filtered water goes
directly to the bladder this explains
why you pee more frequently after
drinking now the organ you've been
waiting for the liver ethanol in the
liver are the oldest rivals in the book
the liver detoxifies about 90 of the
ethanol that you drink into harmless
acetic acid which is then converted into
carbon dioxide and water however ethanol
being the bear that it is doesn't go
down without a fight
before it becomes acetic acid it's
converted into an intermediate
metabolite aceta aldehyde which is very
toxic to the liver acetaldehyde
denatures proteins and liver cells
causing inflammation and apoptosis the
liver is a robust organ and is made to
handle this kind of stuff so the
occasional drink even moderate drinking
is okay but with chronic and heavy
drinking the liver takes a beating from
constant exposure to inflammation in
response to inflammatory injury the
liver grows fibrous connective tissue
known as fibrosis fibrotic tissue is
rigid and non-functional so whatever
tissue becomes fibrotic can no longer
detoxify ethanol or anything toxic in
the body this is known as cirrhosis of
the liver with cirrhosis the body
retains large concentrations of salt in
the abdomen causing an accumulation of
fluid known as edema this leads to the
appearance of a bloated abdomen which is
a telltale sign of a heavy drinker
continued heavy drinking causes
cirrhosis to progress to the point that
the liver is unable to detoxify anything
known as liver failure now the liver is
not the only organ that detoxifies
ethanol if you recall the liver handles
about 90 percent of the ethanol we drink
but what about the remaining 10 percent
oddly enough the pancreas does detoxify
ethanol as well just like the liver the
pancreas converts ethanol into
acetaldehyde and then acetic acid the
pancreas is also injured by inflammation
caused by acetaldehyde however it has a
much lower tolerance to injury than the
liver for moderate drinking the pancreas
is fine it metabolizes a small amount of
alcohol so you're generally okay but
with chronic drinking it can be deadly
the pancreas holds digestive enzymes
that are sent to the intestines for food
breakdown the organ sits behind the
stomach and excretes enzymes into the
beginning of the small intestines these
enzymes are stored in the pancreas and
are not activated until they're released
however the effects of severe
inflammation from acetaldehyde can cause
these inactive enzymes to become
activated and actually digest the
pancreas from the inside out this
persistent injury leads to alcoholic
pancreatitis which is notably painful
what's worse is pancreatitis increases
the risk for pancreatic cancer which is
almost a death sentence and lastly the
final item to the list of the many
things that alcohol does to your body is
it affects your bone i'm telling you
alcohol is the worst thing for you oh
sorry one second
first off light to moderate drinking has
not been shown to adversely affect your
bones so you're okay
not surprisingly though excessive
long-term drinking has been shown to
decrease bone density this more so has
to do with your liver though your bones
are affected down the line if your liver
is in the beginning stages of liver
disease because you drink too much for
far too long its functions begin to drop
in performance one important thing the
liver does aside from detoxification is
it converts vitamin d into its active
metabolite for the body to use to absorb
calcium if your liver is not working the
way it's supposed to you're not
activating enough vitamin d and you're
unable to absorb calcium over time your
bones begin to lose their structural
integrity known as
osteoporosis and that's everything that
alcohol does to your body quick note
this video was not an anti-alcohol video
in case you didn't notice i made the
point several times during the video
that i enjoy drinking alcohol the key
takeaway here is that alcohol really is
not good for you to drink but it's okay
if you drink it in moderation it's only
when you abuse it and you drink it
chronically for many years that you fall
into problems so don't do that so i
shouldn't see any ambiguity or bickering
in the comments okay awesome so
producers we're good here right we're
good to wrap up okay thank you and
writers this this is all good cool and
uh hr is this is this good
no
okay i'll get back to you next week all
right guys that's the video thanks for
watching i'll catch you next time later